respond to shaq
respond to jade
i'd rather just give you the pitch the
classic
sell it my beautiful bride brandy rhodes
against
jade and shaq
were you listening to that i'll tell you
what cupcake cody wrote
oh my god i said you know i'ma beat you
like i almost beat chuck remember when i
gave chuck the left and he flinched
that's how i'm gonna beat you
name the place i'm gonna do it you'll do
what i'm gonna wrestle him
you ain't no right yeah come on man
he'll you want me to do it do you think
we can fight him sure
we want me to do it of course we want
you okay it's done i'm gonna do it
you're gonna do what
i'm gonna wrestle cody rose me and jake
gonna wrestle cody and red
red pumpkin pie you know he's from a
famous wrestling family right i don't
care where he's from i mean i think i i
i
will be like almost with you i won't say
this i've seen shane
when he fought shane mosley and shane
mosley
got a little more than he expected
exactly so i think all right i'm gonna
do it
i'm down do you have a preferred
wrestling move shaq
yes it's called the black tornado would
you demonstrate it
on chuck no no you ain't dog don't hold
your hands on me actually no only
uh covert covert you know protocols but
yeah so yeah so you need
yeah it's called a black tornado you
need somebody what is that what yeah
what is the blood does it look like
although does it look like this oh
it looks like this hold on my man kevin
we've seen the uh this ancient video oh
remember that move right there i
remember that submission hold that kevin
had on you yeah
i forget who moves that is right there
i was hoping maybe you had a sleeper
hold or an abdominal
i like the black tornado let me see can
you give me a
move over the sweater i don't want you
to get hurt
so the black toe actually i don't want
to you know break this glass but you
know the black tomatoes
is when i take the ball and i act like
i'm coming through like this and then i
oh okay i got you oh i got it okay
that's quite enough we get it we get it
that's what i'm gonna do to you cupcake
cody
power that boy like the tortoise i like
the wind blowing
that is some very impressive plexus
you're right right you're right the mask
on you got someone do to you cupcake
cody let us know the date on that okay